the protagonist of the show is a
peculiar girl named Wednesday Adams
despite being only 13. the little girl
barely shows any emotions and has a
weird obsession with death she is also
Infamous for wearing black and white
gothic clothing which everyone finds
strange in the first scene Wednesday
arrives at her high school with a creepy
look on her face inside her locker she
finds her brother Pugsley bound with an
apple in his mouth as she shoves him out
suddenly Wednesday has a vision wherein
she sees who tortured her brother here
we get to know that she is not a normal
child Wednesday has the ability to see
someone's past as well as their future
just by touching them once she finds out
that a group of bullies from the swim
team are behind this she walks into the
swimming room with two bags full of
piranhas then she casually unleashes the
bloodthirsty piranhas in the pool as the
bullies swim for their lives in horror
Wednesday makes it clear that nobody
picks on her brother except her cut to
the next scene we are introduced to
Wednesday's parents Morticia and Gomez
the two are fed up with their daughter's
Shenanigans and have decided to send her
to the prestigious Nevermore Academy it
turns out that all students in this
Academy have supernatural abilities and
they are taught lessons on how to
control them Morticia and Gomez are also
alumni of the same Academy which
indicates that they too have super
powers meanwhile a hiker embarks on a
solo Journey Through the Woods near the
Nevermore Academy unfortunately after
just a few minutes an unknown creature
attacks him and finishes him off the
local sheriff finds the mutilated body
later and begins surveying the area
surprisingly we learned that this grisly
murder isn't the first of its kind there
have been numerous similar incidents as
of late next Wednesday arrives at the
Academy and meets principal Larissa
Weems who seamlessly runs Nevermore she
introduces her to her roommate Enid a
werewolf who's the polar opposite of
Wednesday in every way imaginable Enid
is a Down to Earth girl with vibrantly
colored decorations on her side of the
room while Wednesday Loves All Things
black and Goth later Enid gives
Wednesday a grand tour of the academy
while pointing out the main School
groups fangs Furs Stoners and scales
fangs are vampires Furs or werewolves
Stoners or potheads Gorgons with snakes
on their heads and scales are Sirens who
have the ability to manipulate people
Enid also shows her the most popular
girl in school Bianca Barclay a gorgeous
siren and her ex-boyfriend Xavier Thorpe
a death artist who can transform his
drawings into reality meanwhile as The
Addams Family departs in their car Gomez
releases thing a chopped off living hand
thing is tasked with keeping watch over
their daughter the following day
Wednesday joins fencing class where she
is pitted against the impressive Bianca
after a bit of back and forth the girls
end up with equal points so they decide
to remove their masks and fight until
someone draws blood first soon enough a
brutal battle erupts with both of them
matching each other's stride for stride
however at the end Bianca ultimately
emerges Victorious when she slashes a
small cut on Wednesday cheek later as
Wednesday exits the infirmary after
getting patched up she has almost
crushed to death by a falling stone
gargoyle luckily the death artist Xavier
arrives just in time and pushes her out
of the way shortly after Wednesday
returns to her room but she suspects
that someone is watching her hence she
searches the room and eventually finds
the hand thing realizing that it's her
parents doing Wednesday threatens the
hand to be loyal to her or else she will
lock him up in a drawer terrified thing
vows to be faithful due to Wednesday's
piranha prank she has to take mandatory
therapy sessions so principal Larissa
drives her to her therapy session in
Jericho a small town outside of
Nevermore she meets her therapist but
doesn't open up about anything instead
Wednesday has another idea in mind she
excuses herself to the restroom and
escapes through the window once outside
she accidentally stumbles into a man
suddenly she sees a vision where she
Witnesses the man's death terrified
Wednesday goes to a nearby coffee shop
there she encounters the sheriff's son
Tyler who's also a barista Tyler's
experiencing some mechanical
difficulties with his espresso machine
the directions are inexplicably in
Italian but thankfully Wednesday can
read Italian she fixes the device
effortlessly and in return asks for a
lift to the nearest bus stop but before
Tyler can reply suddenly a trio of
bullies wearing Pilgrim costumes arrive
at the store and taunt her Wednesday
tries ignoring them but when she can't
take it any longer she fights back and
easily smacks them down after a while
principal Larissa arrives at the store
with the sheriff and notices the Carnage
enraged she berates Wednesday before
driving her away from the town on their
way back to the academy they pass a
terrible car wreck the victim is the
same man who Wednesday saw in her vision
earlier later that night she plays a
haunting song on her cello in the dorm
balcony it's a full moon and several
werewolves can be heard howling in the
background however Enid who is a
werewolf herself reveals that she's not
joining them because she cannot
transform herself meanwhile thing pops
by Tyler's room and asks him to call
when's day although terrified he obliges
and the two start video chatting
Wednesday asks Tyler to meet her at the
Harvest Fair the following day claiming
that it will be fun however in reality
she just wants to escape the academy
while at the fair we see Larissa
watching over Wednesday like a hawk
despite this The Goth teenager somehow
manages to catch up with Tyler the two
almost escape the place but just then
Wednesday stumbles into one of her
classmates Rowan he immediately runs
into the woods and since Wednesday
touched him she has a vision Rowan has
been brutally mauled to death by someone
terrified she has a change of heart and
goes after him to impart the news but
before she can say anything Rowan uses
his telekinesis ability and secures her
high up in a tree he then reveals that
his mother a powerful Seer envisioned
Wednesday destroying the Nevermore
Academy 25 years ago hence Rowan
believes that he has to kill her before
anything bad can happen he then starts
choking her telekinetically geez at
least by her telekinetic dinner first
but suddenly a massive monster leaps in
tears Rowan apart and vanishes into thin
air Wednesday stands over his mutilated
body and sees the illustration his
mother supposedly Drew of her soon after
police officers led by the sheriff begin
looking for Rowan's body but are unable
to find it as expected the sheriff does
not believe Wednesday's statement about
a monster attacking Rowan and thinks it
was a Nevermore student instead an
officer disrupts their conversation and
surprisingly we see Rowan who is very
much alive when Wednesday arrives at her
room she notices that her roommate Enid
is too preoccupied with the PO cup
competition an annual boat riding game
later she tries talking to Rowan but
principal Larissa informs her that she
has been expelled for a reason she can't
share as a result Wednesday reverts to
plan B and asks thing to keep an eye on
Rowan the scene then cuts to Rowan who
has arrived at the train station with
thing following closely behind after
observing the surroundings he covertly
heads to the restroom and changes his
appearance into that of an old man and
fortunately thing loses track of him and
misses this transformation later the old
man changes to principal Arisa this
reveals that she is actually a
shape-shifter and for some reason she is
covering up Rowan's murder left with no
options Wednesday Ventures into the
woods to look for Rowan's murder Clues
she is accompanied by Tyler who is
stalking his dad after a while she finds
Rowan's glasses and as she picks them up
she has a vision in the vision she sees
a purple book from which Rowan got the
drawing wasting no time Wednesday
confronts her class teacher about the
book and the latter reveals that it
belonged to an old student society
called the nightshades however the
society has long since disbanded after
school Wednesday sneaks into Rowan's
room to look for the book she finds a
mask underneath his bed but before she
can leave Xavier arrives it turns out he
is Rowan's roommate Wednesday quickly
hides under the bed and right then
Bianca also arrives to visit her ex she
overhears their conversation and learns
that Bianca is planning to crush Enid in
the upcoming boat riding competition
hence as soon as she returns to her room
Wednesday decides to help Enid by
joining the competition so that they can
take Bianca down the next day Wednesday
anina to gear up for the competition as
there are no rules it is all fair game
and Bianca is using this to her
Advantage there are four teams and the
game is that they have to row their boat
to a destination and back whoever is the
first one to arrive at the Finish Line
without being knocked out in the lake is
declared the winner as the contest
begins Bianca hints at one of her
friends who is ready to sabotage the
other boats the friend who turns out to
be a mermaid dives into the lake and
destroys one of the boats knocking the
team out thankfully Wednesday and Enid
are prepared so with the help of thing
they managed to capture the mermaid
however during the contest Wednesday has
another Vision this time she sees a
blonde hair version of herself and that
version tells her she is the key
confused Wednesday snaps into reality
only to find that Bianca's team is
leading the race unwilling to give up
she and Enid decide to play dirty they
used Beyond Bianca's underhand methods
against her and finally win the
competition with this a non-syrent team
has won the esteemed competition for the
first time in four decades later the
winning team is honored by principal
Larissa who handed the pokeup trophy
however Wednesday is unable to withstand
the attention so she finds Solace with
Edgar Allan Poe a former student of the
Nevermore Academy suddenly she sees a
symbol underneath the stone book he's
holding it is the same symbol that was
carved in the picture Rowan had handed
her before he was mauled to death
Wednesday quickly solves a series of
riddles etched in the book and finds a
clue that is snapping twice
when she snaps twice suddenly a secret
Corridor opens revealing a hidden
chamber if this Academy had a beat
Poetry Club this portal would not be a
secret there Wednesday successfully
finds Rowan's book from which he had
torn the picture she puts the book in
her backpack but before she can go
further someone thrusts a black sack
over her head shortly after when the
sack is taken off she finds herself
surrounded by Bianca Xavier and a few
more students who are members of the
nightshades club turns out although the
group was previously disbanded principal
Arissa reinstated it secretly Xavier
urges Wednesday to join their group but
she straight away refuses and walks away
in the next scene we see principal
Larissa announcing the annual Outreach
day where the Nevermore students will
have to mingle with normal people also
known as normies by working alongside
them at their establishments once they
arrive in town Wednesday tells Xavier
that his roommate might have been
murdered the latter doesn't think Rowan
is dead because he was only expelled
despite this Wednesday shows him the
pitch Rowan's mother Drew Xavier takes a
close look at it and reveals that the
man in the picture is actually the
founder of Jericho Joseph crackstone a
while later Wednesday decides to
volunteer in the pilgrim world the place
that holds Jericho's history there she
meets Eugene a young boy she had
befriended in the beekeeping Club the
two immediately get to talking and start
observing the surroundings soon the
students are approached by Miss Arlene
the caretaker of the pilgrim world she
gives them a tour and talks about some
of Joseph crackstone's beloved artifacts
Wednesday asks more about the artifacts
and learns that they have original farm
tools tableware and even the family
chamber pot ew she wants to work there
but can't because it's being renovated
instead they're all going to work at the
yield fudgery to distribute fudge and
cakes to the local tourists later
Wednesday with the assistance of Eugene
sneaks into the crackstone family
chamber she finds a painting of the old
meeting house which includes the girl
from her vision shortly after she also
finds the book that the girl carrying
however when Wednesday notices that the
pages are blank she suspects it is a
fake just then the caretaker Arlene
arrives and catches her Wednesday asks
about the original book and Arlene
hesitantly reveals that it was stolen
last month later Tyler and Wednesday
reunited the coffee shop the latter
inquires about Joseph crackstone and
Tyler reveals that what is left of the
original meeting house is out in the
woods it is pretty much a ruin and meth
heads use the place as a crash pad
immediately Wednesday and thing entered
the woods in search of Joseph
crackstone's place they eventually find
it and come across a homeless man but
thing chokes him and scares him away
what the hell thing suddenly Wednesday
experiences a vision this time she
travels 400 years into the past we see
the blonde girl she encountered in the
earlier vision there are villagers who
are encircling the girl as they call her
the devil's spawn soon Joseph crackstone
arises from the crowd and calls her
goody Adams he accuses her of being a
witch and condemns her to die in a barn
stuffed with other accused folk
including her mother in turn goody also
accuses them of stealing their land
slaughtering the innocent and robbing
them of their peaceful Spirit enraged
Joseph stares at her for a while and
then sets the barn Ablaze goody tries to
free your mom but all her efforts are in
vain at last when there is no hope left
she escapes via a trapdoor meanwhile
Wednesday observes all of this in the
barn with them goody soon runs up to her
and claims that Joseph won't cease his
Crusade until he's killed them all with
this Revelation Wednesday wakes up from
her lengthy vision and explains
everything to thing I think we found
someone who it's cool for you to choke
thing suddenly they see the same monster
that killed Rowan lurking behind them
Wednesday runs after it in the rain but
can't keep up hence she follows the
footprints which strangely start
transforming into a human's this reveals
that the monster is actually a human
right then she runs into Xavier and
tells him what she saw he wants to look
at the tracks but the rain has already
washed them away the following day
everyone reunites in the Town Square for
the unveiling of a new Statue dedicated
to Joseph craxton Stone Wednesday plays
an instrumental version of Fleetwood
Mac's don't stop with the Jericho
marching band while the mayor and
Larissa announced the statue however
disaster ensues when thing as per
Wednesday's orders sets the statue in
Flames While others run away in horror
Wednesday's eyes gleam with vengeance as
she swiftly plays the cello later
principal erisa tears into Wednesday
suspecting the she caused the incident
however the teenager refuses to have
done anything and instead confronts
Larissa for refusing to acknowledge the
bloody racist truth on which Jericho was
founded hell yeah that night the
homeless man from earlier is being
attacked by the monster and his camera
begins taking pictures of the incident
moments later the sheriff and his crew
arrive at the forest ruins and find the
homeless man dead they discover footage
on his camera that may reveal the
culprit's face after developing the
photos the sheriff looks upon the face
of the killer a monster born from
nightmares be sure to check out the next
episodes of this series as we come cover
them on series Recaps on